first of all I want to say how shocked
and saddened I am that three people have
lost their lives earlier today in
Nottingham and that further individuals
have been injured in this tragic
incident we're in a very early stage of
the investigation we need to allow the
police the time and the space to carry
out all of their operational activity to
determine the motive it's right that
Nottinghamshire police are working with
counter terrorism policing but it's also
fair to say that everybody in all
professionals on the front line are
keeping an open mind as to what the
precise motive might have been there are
some things we do know right now we
obviously know that sadly tragically
three people have been killed we know
that a knife has been used in some of
those killings and a suspect has been
arrested on suspicion of Murder By
Nottinghamshire police